Oh
my name is Jess MacDonald hi I'm sorry T
and Y can fly again collation we're
second so what's this about
siliceous is the son of the devil it is
a sequel to the first game yet which was
published yes this is Lucius to the
prophecy it's basically a continuation
picks up exactly where the previous game
left off except this time around it's an
open sandbox laughing and you go around
killing people as a summer it's just a
real bad kid and we're gonna cause some
trouble so let's let's do that let's
let's go straight into it and get into
the game now that's all the same
developer shiver games so a lot of the
game is uh still very similar like looks
the same but yeah we go down mad little
suit which we picked up at the start of
the game so basically we were taken away
from Dante Manor where we spent the last
game killing every member of our family
and now we're in a hospital to wreak
more havoc they obviously took us here
for our own care but we're going to
repay that by doing the murders that's
right killing everyone so we've kind of
just been like running around and like
the first intro part involved well
killing people and it's just it's very
mad to be here so now I can take revenge
on everyone who does the lesson what I
think
and look the text like on the wall it's
interesting because this text isn't
everywhere yeah all these items from the
game have like attributes so this is a
can of flammable it's flammable and pick
up our attribute and you can see that
it's blunt yes so this is supposed to
help you with with the killing of the
people who probably don't deserve to be
killed you can spite that misogynistic
joke you just they're just bros gonna
let that one slide no he's not gonna let
that one slide it depends if we can get
this candidate throwing things with my
mind is much hotter than it sounds you
can drag it with your mind all year oh
yeah he's not moving ah oh yeah there's
a little
goodness oh you filled the camp's well
it's a flammable can you know I'm
looking at oh I level up from that Oh
so this is something that's new with
lochester yeah it's quite a complicated
skill tree and you get to customize in a
way you didn't win the first game which
is a lot more linear man
so this super super dead having food
okay okay
can I walk through that I mean I'm the
devil right yeah you go telekinesis over
the fire
so these cakes also have numbers
associated with them
yep I can take the boys don't want to
drag them quite out into the way so this
is a new key that we've got down the
bottom
the keys are live apparently not
arbitrary one-year-old names but yeah we
do have a map say we can tell it'll cost
well this key goes five six five one oh
I'm kind of like everybody remember I'm
gonna go ahead he's like going into this
yes it's hard to let things go and
should keep them up this is the
incredibly intrusive map which you can
also see on the bottom right hand corner
at the screen is following me isn't he
Oh mom I didn't go and let him go
someone's gonna see him I'll hide them
in the truth lights
or is he crouching hotel blah blah blah
clerk alright so henceforth you shall be
known as Ludlow all is that the The
Devil's son oh seven
I don't know does it enable them deadly
seems we should have funny that you're
right all right mind control fuel oh
this is good you hit him here you should
let go of him now
I'm trying you gotta cover everything an
attack like we can find the nuns room
well he's in a state of suspicion and
panic and he's also insane reminder too
insane
he seems to be mumbling something let's
go find this nun and definitely not kill
her I think we're gonna kill because
she's a nun I tie she's the one that he
tried to kill at the beginning they they
have a sort of history so perhaps Oh our
map is actually giving us the direction
yeah so the start of the game we did
open up the hospital which is why all
these doors are open and also because
they've is asleep hospital doors open
yeah also let us wonder about fairly
freely we should be able to kill
somebody hey that's the janitor oh no
the cross in her think that sounds good
to have in your inventory
I don't forget some tools and more
flammable liquids so we can't get
somebody near at all then I reckon we'll
be good to go
so no oh good he couldn't find me oh
good he bullied me
gosh missus I'll hide in the showers he
won't know like you know like electrify
the show oh my gosh okay okay are we
getting closer I just need something to
directly throw at him to kill anyway I
don't think that it does the trick on me
that usually work during us oh I do have
donors we did find out at the start of
the game you can combine der nuts and
pills I think you've got pills at the
top left that's yeah and and apparently
doughnuts are appealing so no matter
what the situation going on the NPC's
will be like ooh Donuts oh did you
combine them with the donut I did so
these are the poisoned and if you just
throw them at people you wild they'll be
like oh here we go here we come oh he's
gonna turn us a third er nuts
eat the donut donut just like how and a
mental patient
this place is insane like someone needs
to get a handle on it but I love how
when you kill someone it's just like I
like the holy course coming from around
like Oh as if I get was a good thing but
he also dropped the keys to the nuns
room which is exactly so now we can kill
I feel very bad I don't want at this
start I don't want to kill them the last
game we were conflicted between wanting
to achieve things but also feeling a
little
I know it's really really this is
experience right here they so we are
marking we gonna throw something at that
to turn it around good we got the
throwables that's not throw a flammable
bottle at look that's probably can't
afraid kids where the son of the devil a
food not a big not a big requirement not
a big deal okay yes I met oh let's just
let's go with the physics of that Matt
Mike is experienced
he makes peace good Oh the nonce room
was filled with religious ticks she was
not there she's over fourth full mmm
done well guess that's where we go even
it is unless we can kill more people on
the way I can carry you like multiple
bottles of things no pockets for days oh
my god
well we did really well with the door
not so I mean I'm really pleased with
that James having a good time my
patients are a little interesting oh
okay so this room on the right up there
had a bunch of home and then on your
right-hand side I believe this room
alright I'm exciting okay this might if
we pull the can the canister outside
right then we break it we put it in me
this patience and then we throw the
flammable things I reckon we can do some
damage but we also might get it all
wrong and die well we might get it I
don't want to kill the mental patient
though do we we have to get rid of back
of it the way the son of a devil
right with you I'm happy to get rid of
the snow guards well the problem that
exercises the text also says you can use
tools to break items well okay and
what's with the red lines is that you
know tell me something I know oh no
that's well that's the direction it's
exploding in I don't know
oh I can aim this exploding pants I
don't want to pretend that I know okay
so do we want to blow up these guys are
doing it yeah let's give it all right oh
it's like hey oh this works I opted a
little bit too much man that mental arm
of mine just goes too far do we have to
break it first
I think it's tools I feel like oh you
can use tools maybe we should walk up to
it negative the chemists are you want to
stand next to the chemist I think I'll
just throw this can see you to all your
genius older male hello nerd but now
it's open it's there and it's open I
can't pick it up
I think it maybe it's gas is gone oh
maybe this is a really complicated let's
move on Oh take that mole oh I think I
know what to do so that red line
actually indicated which way the
canister was gonna get the next set and
try again yeah okay I'll shoot the guy
good idea
okay see it's a learning experience it's
not failure it's just letting okay it's
okay I like this I can't believe that
actually works that was phenomenal but
we were positively phenomenal that's
wonderful okay oh now I'm sorry
Oh
tells me only tells me my gonna be good
friends with this Canada yeah I think
he's dead oh well that was that follow
us he's not a bit experienced let's just
leave that one alone I guess cousin
Ronnie maybe he went with with God
instead of Lucifer
well anyway well now I just leave the
floor passing thing that help us on the
devil can I bring him back with
something I don't think so well maybe at
the end of the game maybe we'll have a
little reunion all right um okay so
we're we going well listeners we need to
leave the floor okay oh no someone's
coming
I think that's just the mental patient I
don't think he's an enemy oh okay well
that's all right
I think it's just a crazy person being
crazy you know doing crazy dude that
guy's peeing on a plan oh that's good we
did the thing I I picked up zero
disgrace symbols tonight Ramona skills a
total body count is five good job and I
wasn't even suspected at all not even a
suspect they think anything all of the
little boy running around the hospital
in a three-piece suit that's fine just
wasting
oh my goodness no she only had questions
what we all have Oh
Steven he's gonna avenge him liar why
was everyone talking about this setup I
reckon but non-earth has something to do
I have the prophesy begun without him
the fourth-floor have a library
oh he's go fool anybody's got followers
every way he's made he's made quite a
lot of friends I mean he's been here for
six months so oh that's right yeah oh
yeah happens it happens
all right that's good right now well
this is the longest elevator ride in
history just like massive it just wants
us to contemplate our lives
sweet well here we are we will have
malicious game actually got a load of
terrible puns so good I was saying that
again now the maps telling me to go this
way I feel like I should have wait oh no
I can't really go anywhere in here why
do you tell me that well so apparently
this game does have full levels worth of
hospital so that's a whole area you can
explore and then eventually from my
understanding you do get out of it and
you can go wreak havoc elsewhere but
although it looks pretty cool I don't
know what do you think I like staying in
the hospital there's plenty of things to
do yeah I used to mess with and you know
people would have messed me yeah
checking you're gonna get into more of
this game do more the more the killings
I don't know man I kind of also feel
really bad each time we execute someone
don't feel really wrong and certainly
some guilt is eating Donuts PZ
I don't think I have pills in them so
they're not doing us any favors at old
alright we're gonna pick up more
some pills and oh god there's people
everywhere Oh God oh she's working in
securities for Kaos man there is so much
text everywhere but it seems like me
walking near the nurse this isn't
arousing any suspicion yes I mean you
can be careful like there's some stealth
elements and there's some clever puzzle
II stuff where you got to find out
interesting ways to kill people but um
yeah those are a few of them I think
we'll uh we'll probably leave you guys
to explore and Maine and do terrible
things but um yeah it's fun it's fun
times isn't it and food taking food out
of him and taking food out of bins and
hopefully not arousing suspicion
did he just flush the 12 mean bathroom
with this Wow these people yeah oops
awesome accidental telekinesis worst
problems to have well he's good with the
chaos loser so he's doing yeah nurse is
like not even reacting to this self
hovering around on this end yeah just
another day in the mental hospital I
mean you take advantage of the crappy
yeah it's just it's just a little more
of an enjoyment for you I mean if they
were too clever oh man it's like so
chaotic that it's hilarious yeah yeah
well I think that's also will probably
wrap it there mm-hmm
but you can play let's just say if you
want it is on the steam it is for 20
bucks and you can just have watched us
play right now and and all the fun and
see all the terrible terrible things
that we do to good people
thanks for joining us if you want to
check out the previous playthrough first
Lucius game that we did you can find
that on the danceable page as well
tourism hopefully you enjoy that yeah
you